1979 was a momentous year in the Middle East — the Egyptian-Israeli peace treaty,
Saddam Hussein becoming president of Iraq, and the Soviet invasion of Afghanistan.
But in retrospect, the most significant event was the Iranian revolution, an anniversary
we mark on February 11.
The revolution removed the Shah, who
had been our chief proxy in this strategically
vital but highly volatile part of the world.
Worse, it brought to power a regime that has
defined the US as its principal
enemy ever since, despite repeated efforts
by American administrations to find a path
toward peace.
Since 1979, the most constant threat we've faced in the region has been Iran’s relentless
enmity — which it has aggressively pursued
by killing Americans,
attacking American military forces and allies,
and arming groups that seek to overturn the
regional status quo by violence.
As Americans debate our role in the
Middle East, it’s worth remembering why
many fear it would be dangerous to leave.
Iran’s dogged aggression against the United
States, its friends and interests, which started
40 years ago.
What do you think the future holds for US-Iran relations?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.